[Music]
today Alliance is best known to dota 2
fans as the Swedish roster that
conquered the international three and
one of the most dramatic grand finals
ever that's gonna try to cancel as many
as possible but some travel
but in the lead up to ti3 many fans
would have been surprised to see a CIS
and a European team duking it out in the
finals that's because a different region
had dominated the previous international
China international - they're going on
hogging the Chinese flags come in the
bride on this team China took five of
the top eight spots at ti2
with Invictus gaming winning it all and
besides Navi who faced off against IG in
the grand finals the remaining teams in
top eight were from Southeast Asia some
fans had begun to wonder if dota 2 would
resemble its dota 1 roots where the
Chinese and SCA teams were dominant
secretive and seemingly in surpass evil
yeah China was the be-all end-all like
there was there was no one that was able
to stand up to them but the Chinese were
also very secretive they never even
released their replays for six months
after a game was played just out of fear
that some will be able to see their
strategies and analyze them deep in in
high detail Southeast Asia was insanely
strong Singapore Malaysia had rivalries
back then Vietnam was a huge help as
well but Alliance already one of the
strongest teams in 2013 set out to prove
the scene wrong they set out to show
that a European team and what it took to
dominate in this new game and they did
it by bringing the fight to China and
beating the Chinese teams on their home
soil
well beating is putting it mildly
Alliance made a statement at g1 allying
season 5 they dominated the Chinese team
by going undefeated
the g1 Champions League was one of the
largest tournaments in the world leading
up to ti3 and though the tournament
itself only boasted six teams the
lengthy qualifier saw many of the best
teams in the world compete the top two
teams from the Western qualifier
Alliance and Team Liquid both earned
spots in the round-robin group stage
going for the jugular but they're not
done yet the stunt will hit ice Mike
trixie dropping low it comes no tail
again and he's going to die again he
will go down and that's gotta be it
no crumpet no span liquid are gonna hang
on and take Game two they've just puts
their tickets of China liquid there
they're going to China can you believe
it what a performance a game two gonna
be the next of the list of casualties
Audie trying to feed scrip just can't
get the job done
Dotel REE engages bouncing around the
BKB but the damage just not enough arrow
still down era does not have buyback
Congrats s fnatic and Alliance and very
impressive fashion to to nothing they
punched their ticket to Shanghai Team
Liquid struggled in the group stage
going one and four it was to a certain
extent what we'd come to expect from
foreign teams on Chinese soil in 2012
during the first dota 2 G 1 season evil
genius has made it to the online round
of six but fell just short of the land
semi finals
meanwhile Alliance carve the path to the
birthday
and that'll be that the chi chi's come
out so in the first game of the g1 y
bland vitals a Western team steals a win
hell they didn't steal it
they kicked in the door bashed him in
the head and took it
13 to 28 the final kill score on Lions
looks good in Beijing they beat China's
best teams they meet Team Liquid they
meet everybody
they went five and O and qualified
directly for the grand finals
3 IG here instead rest is going to take
a full faith coast EEG haiji enough out
of the g1 league LAN finals Alliance
they do what many people thought would
be impossible they go 500 in the group
stage they take down all three Chinese
teams they take that aren't say take out
liquid and this is just such a fantastic
moment for the second place team in the
round-robin LGD gaming 202's EA's orange
esports to make it to the grand finals
and so the stage was set in shanghai
hike crowd top teams a huge prize it was
even hockey's birthday a win for either
team would mean a sizeable chunk of
money
but it would also give a ton of momentum
heading to ti3 but alliance were there
to make a statement they were there to
put the international community on
notice aligns the the foreigner the
weaker teams coming from this unknown
country through these Chinese guys to
China and they are just beating up on
everybody they were flawless they have 5
and other groups undefeated undefeated
and made it look pretty easy the thing
to understand about Alliance at this
time is that they were known for a very
particular style of dota a style that
emphasized admiralbulldog lone druid and
nature's prophet allowed s force will be
used a very overpowered batrider and
focused on farming up unassailable carry
and it's just gonna work get someone
kill gets a double kill TC possibly baby
but it's tanking the Roshan is getting
bashed and now load up will be taking
the ancient I think eg I'm getting
positions disruption comes in puffs
though blinks and snacks in just now
it's gonna go to work again sold
unfortunately doesn't have a damn just
sighs come to I guess pork or it's gonna
go they're gonna see buff is gonna get
initiative on who's gonna die choose
basically everybody's reality I don't
know three hits gems who's gonna get
dropped as well and this gotta be and
what you have to realize about the
Chinese dota squads then and now is that
they're often unwilling to bend to
Western Metatron's if a Western team is
convinced that a certain strategy is
Metta defining Chinese teams will be
sometimes reluctant to ban it even if
they lose to it in the grand finals LGD
did not ban Bulldogs lone druid they did
not ban batrider they would not bend to
the Western meta
an alliance took advantage of that you
give away lone druid lifestealer it's
very hard to stop both of them from
farming later on it's hard to deal with
at least one of them if not both I
completely agree it's really hard there
you go hobo hesitation I mean it's not
surprising at all game one got off to a
slow start but it was exactly the stern
Alliance wanted with their quarrel
lifestealer and lone druid combo getting
comfortable farm leaves you look at the
Alliance of their two solos played out
of their mind 16 and 4 on bulldog with
no centuries still keeping the pace with
sigh lark it could have gotten a 1st
floor.there with the route s4 crushing
the mid lane this is what he's known for
many call him the best solo in all of
europe if not all of the way they took
Roche at 20 minutes and then a huge
teamfight 10 minutes later there was
nothing LGD could do he knows what in
the water so does his squad the Alliance
this week they're gonna take Game one
Gigi from LGD the Alliance had this
every step of the way I never felt like
LGD had a chip draft I gotta give it to
alliance as well as they just have
better lanes they have better heroes I
just got a
give away launcher Life Alert on the
Alliance you are begging for trouble so
game to LGD gave alliance whatever they
wanted and LGD got stomped surely they
had to make an adjustment right well
Bhoomi should LGD have given this all
away no a line feel comfortable heading
at the game too
they got everything they wanted out of
the draft we've got admiralbulldog on
his signature hero on the lone druid
will have s4 on one of his signature
heroes the batrider and though LGD got
some picks that could take a beating and
win leaking team fights it wasn't enough
Alliance got everything they wanted out
of the game - I didn't even want to show
that 2500 gold 2500 experienced LGD I
already feel like they're on the ropes
up against this lineup of the Alliance
they needed to win that trial and their
gifts getting hammered all around the
map this is just brutal to watch my
friend
I know it's a finals of a tournament LGD
I have not seen a team get manhandled
this hard in the grand finals of such a
major event in a long time the Alliance
are making LGD look silly if they go on
to win this game though one of the most
impressive single LAN performances ever
I love that decision Oh a blink a crit
and probably a kill s for diving LGD in
the shadow of their foul GG from chalet
at the Alliance are your g1 league
season 5 champions they take home over
$40,000 and a lot of pride for free
alliance came to China ready for a fight
we're need to take on some of the best
teams in the world and they conquer them
all huge congratulations to Alliance
they are a flawless team at least at
this moment they've taken down
absolutely everyone going undefeated
this tournament three months before ti3
set the tone for the rest of the season
and though there were plenty of great
teams that entered dota 2 biggest
tournament that August Alliance cemented
themselves as a team to beat at ti3
and no one did but why are we talking
about g1 League five years later for one
thing it was the first time a Western
dota team had to win a premier
tournament against Chinese team on
Chinese soil it means something when a
foreign team comes onto Chinese soil and
Wednesday early cement a metal back then
and for China g1 was a wake-up call and
it kind of kicked the Chinese into gear
I remember Shawn actually coming up on
stage as well trying to rally most of
China and Southeast Asia because he was
like we're all playing like crap right
now like we're all accepting streaming
gigs and we're not practicing enough
we're playing RPGs on the side like we
should be doing so much better than this
because these teams over here are so
much better than us today it's easy to
remember the breathtaking hives of ti3
to remember those incredible grand
finals to take ourselves back to those
dream coils but the ti3 season wasn't
just about alliances incredible win it
was a time when the Swedish team was
redefining analyst expectations of the
west eventually China fired back of
course new b1 ti4 and took the Angus
back to the East and so the cycle has
continued on and on for years but
without that incredible 2013 season
without g1 league without ti3 maybe that
newbie roster never would have happened
maybe the Chinese teams would have never
been jolted out of their complacency and
into eventually but that win and she won
a league was one of the first signs that
showed that Alliance had what it took to
take their place in the ti cycle
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]